Okay, encouragement for members who only have enough positive cashflow to run one campaign
at a time to get clients with, makes things move at a snail's pace.
So yeah, I mean, the way I look at it, guys, is this, right?
If you guys get in that situation where you're like, man, of course, Nick can do 24K in a
month.
He's got money to run.
I do.
But guys, remember that in 2019, not only did I not have money to run ads, I had $60,000
in debt.
And not only did I have $60,000 in debt, I had two car payments and not only did I have
two car payments, I had a house payment and I had a wife and I had a couple of kids and
I had this and I had that and I had bills and I think all the stuff and my wife just
because I didn't have money didn't mean she doesn't want to go on vacation and she wasn't
on Instagram and she wasn't talking to her friends who are going to Disneyland.
Guys, I've been there.
Okay.
So my encouragement is that you have to look at it like, okay, first of all, let's not
be stupid.
Let's not go blow money, obviously, but also at the same time, let's just be really good
about where we put our money.
And yes, for the first little bit, it might feel like it's running at a snail's speed,
but guess what?
Once you get that first deal, it opens up a little cash and then instead of taking the
cash and just go blowing it on something stupid, let's put it back in the business.
And now maybe we can run too, but we're going to be smart about it.
We're not just going to go burn in cash and boom, we got two deals.
Okay, cool.
Things are starting to go and now maybe we need to get a VA, right?
So I think the thing I would tell you is like, the encouragement is I was there.
I was there in 2019 when I was figuring this out.
I was like, dude, what do I have to work with?
What can I sell?
What can I do?
Which one of my sites that I built in another program is generating some leads that fits
the criteria and has low CPC.
And yeah, for the first couple of months running this strategy, guys, I was doing them one
at a time.
Literally, it was one at a time until we went and said, let's do 10K in a month.
And then we started doing two or three.
So I think it gets frustrating.
We see everyone else smash the deal, smash the deal, smash the deals.
Trust me, guys.
I know that it could get frustrating, but also you got to realize just because it's
taking you, whoever you are to get your first, it's taking you longer.
I heard this quote one time and it gets over quoted, but like, I think it's we overestimate
what we can do in a year and we underestimate what we can do in five.
And some of you guys are overestimating what you can do in one month or two months or six
months.
Guys, if I would have stopped, I started doing this in 2016.
If I would have stopped, if I would have at the year two mark or the year three mark,
if I would have stopped and been like, well, guys, at the end of year three, I had made
a couple hundred grand in three years.
And then in literally in eight months, I went to a hundred grand a month and made seven
figures in one freaking year.
We underestimate what we can do or we overestimate what we can do in, you know, one year.
And for some of you guys, one month and we underestimate what we can do in five years.
The reason why I'm patient, but I'm still hustling, but I'm patient is because I'm going
to be doing this.
I don't care what recession comes.
I don't care what business opportunity comes.
I don't care who comes across my plate or what partnership comes, but I'm going to be
doing this.
And I promise you, for those of you that are like already shiny object syndrome, looking
at other stuff and, oh, there's this thing over here, you'll be back.
And guess who's still going to be here?
Your boy, the king of digital real estate and the crown is going to be a lot freaking
bigger when you come back.
Okay.
I'm going to be here.
So that's why I don't get upset.
I'll get worked up when Google changes the GMB and the recession's coming and it's winter.
It's like, so, so I'm in this man.
Good question though.